Phönix vor
Ort hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu
Phönix vor Ort eine Sondersendung zur
Lage in Israel und dem Nahen Osten guten
Morgen es ist genau eine Woche her dass
die Terrororganisation Hamas damit
begonnen hat israelische Städte massiv
mit Raketen zu beschießen na Israel
einzudringen und dort auf grausamste und
brutalste Weise Menschen zu töten
Geiseln zu nehmen und zu verschleppen
seitdem läuft in Israel eine
Gegenoffensive und obwohl die
israelische Armee mittlerweile in Gaza
hunderte Ziele bombardiert hat um die
Hamas zu schwächen zum Teil auch
israelische Soldaten in Gaza vorgestoßen
sind finden noch immer jeden Tag
Beschuss statt müssen die Menschen in
israelischen Städten wie Aschkelon und
Tel Aviv in Luftschutzbunker vor Raketen
fliehen auch die deutsche
Außenministerin Annalena berbock hat das
bei ihrem Besuch gestern in Israel
erlebt die aktuellen Entwicklung
in raketenalarm im Krankenhaus von
Aschkelon im Süden Israels mehr als 600
Patienten sind seit Samstag hier
eingeliefert worden 100 inzwischen
verstorben zweimal wurde die Klinik
bereits von Raketen getroffen alle
Patienten mussten in Zimmer im Keller
verlegt werden Alltag für viele
israelinnen und Israelis in diesen
Tagen knapp 40 km weiter südlich in der
Nähe des Gazastreifens besucht au
Ministerin berbock die Dörfer die die
Hamas am Wochenende angegriffen und
teils völlig zerstört hat es sind Bilder
der grultaten die der deutschen
Außenministerin gezeigt werden
vergangenen Samstag verschleppten
Mitglieder der Terrororganisation
Zivilisten in den Gazastreifen Menschen
wurden wahlos getötet bbock ist
sichtlich bewegt betont Deutschlands
Solidarität mit
Israel israel hat das Recht nein die
Pflicht ih
Angehörigen zu
befreien israel hat das Recht ja die
Pflicht sich im Rahmen des
internationalen Rechts gegen diesen
brutalen barbarischen Terror zu wehren
den Alltag der Menschen in Israel
bekommt auch
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von derlin zu
spüren sie ist mit einer Delegation nach
Israel gereist wegen eines raketenalarms
muss sie in einem Bunker Schutz suchen
der Beginn der israelischen
Bodenoffensive drückt wohl näher das
Land hat zwar eine viel größere Armee
als die Hamas doch könnte die
Terrororganisation in Straßenkämpfen
ihre Ortskenntnisse gegen das
israelische Militär ausspielen zudem
verstecken sich vermutlich
hamasfunktionäre im Gazastreifen in den
nach eigenen Angaben insgesamt hunderte
Kilometer langen Tunneln unter
bohnblocks Krankenhäusern und Schulen
israelischen Bodentruppen steht
möglicherweise ein komplizierter Einsatz
bevor also man muss davon ausgehen dass
man quasium
360° um sich drum herum haben kann das
heißt also nicht nur von links oder
rechts sondern auch von oben und von
unten durch das Tunnelsystem durch im
Häuserkampf Leute die über einem stehen
und von dort aus Kämpfen durch die
vielen unterschiedlichen Gebäude die da
sind als sehr risikoreiche Situation für
die israelische Armee weiteres Ziel die
mehr als 100 Geiseln zu befreien die die
Hamas in ihrer Gewalt hat Familie AR
bankt um die 19jährige Karina in den
sozialen Netzwerken ist ein Video
dass sie zusammen mit zwei anderen
Frauen liegend in einem Auto zeigen
soll weiß nicht ob es gut oder schlecht
ist dass unsere Armee in den
Gazastreifen
einmarschiert ich will unsere Kinder
wieder das ist alles was ich
möchte auch Soldaten befinden sich in
der Gewalt der Hamas die Experten
rechnen mit einer längeren
bodenoperation die letzte große
Offensive im
gaserreifenuli 2014 und dauerte fast 2
Monate und in Tel Aviv kann ich jetzt
sprechen mit unserem Korrespondenten
Christian Limpert guten Morgen nach Tel
Aviv können Sie vielleicht kurz einmal
sagen wie war denn die
Nacht guten Morgen wir hatten hier eine
relativ ruhige Nacht es gab in Tel Aviv
seit gestern Abend keinen raketenalarm
mehr keine Sirenen
also auch keinen Beschuss hier durch
Raketen der Hamas aus dem gaserstreifen
dennoch gab es Alarm etwas im Süden vor
erst wenigen Stunden und auch die
Operationen D die Attacken des
israelischen Militärs Aufstellungen der
Hamas in Gaza die ging heute Nacht
weiter der Terrorangriff der Hamas ist
ja jetzt genau eine Woche her wie ist
denn mittlerweile die Stimmung im
Land es sind verschiedene Stimmungen zum
einen ist immer noch der Schock und der
überwiegt auch noch
angesichts dieser schrecklichen Bilder
die jetzt seit einer Woche äh teilweise
immer noch neu dazu kommen die neuen
Informationen über äh diese furchtbaren
Angriffe diese furchtbaren Massaker in
den Orten aber auch über das Schicksal
der der der Menschen die verschleppt
wurden nach Gaser also da ist noch ein
großer Schock gleichzeitig
merken wir auch mehr und mehr ein
zusammenhalten es gibt viele
freiwilligen Verbände Organisationen die
nun versuchen mit allen möglichen
Unterstützungen
z.B einfaches Sandwich schmieren für das
Militär das jetzt zusammengezogen wir
drund um den gaserstreifen klar zu
machen dass man als
Gesellschaft momentan zusammensteht und
es kommt schon auch zunehmend die Frage
und ein bisschen die Wut darüber wie so
etwas passieren konnte wie einer der
besten Geheimdienste der Welt so einen
massiven Angriff nicht bemerkt und eine
sehr hochgerüstete und gut ausgebildete
Armee diesem Angriff auch völlig wehrlos
gegenüberst das ist tatsächlich etwas
das wahrscheinlich später genau wird
aufgearbeitet werden müssen her limbert
das sind ja vereinzelt israelische
Soldaten in Gaza können Sie das
beurteilen ist das der Beginn dieser
Bodenoffensive davon ist auszugehen
vielleicht vorne weg es gab schon vor
dieser Bodenoffensive Militärexperten
die gesagt haben m es kommt vielleicht
nicht sofort zu einer großen
Bodenoffensive im Sinne von Einmarsch
mit vielen Truppen sondern so zu
gezielten punktuellen Aktionen genau wie
wir sie gestern gesehen haben und in
einer Fernsehansprache am Abend hat
Premierminister netanahu ja auch gesagt
das sei erst der Anfang hat das Ziel
noch einmal bekräftigt die Hamas in Gaza
komplett zu zerschlagen also ja es ist
davon auszugehen dieser Einsatz war ein
Beginn der Offensive eine erste Aktion
es ist auch durchaus möglich dass das
jetzt für einige Zeit so weitergeht das
heißt Angriffe des israelischen Militärs
aus der Luft und am Boden gezielte
Operationen aber eben erstmal keine kein
großer Einsatz von Bodentruppen und was
man eben gestern
gesehen hat oder auch gefunden hat ist
äh der der Hinweis der Beweis für erste
getötete israelische Geiseln in Gaza das
hat das
das haben israelische Medien heute früh
noch einmal gemeldet dass bei dieser
Operation von Spezialkräften in Gaza
gestern wohl Leichen auch gesehen wurden
es ist ja heute in Israel Schabbat
ändert das eigentlich etwas am
militärischen Vorgehen oder ist sowas
jetzt sozusagen
ausgesetzt also grundsätzlich lässt sich
das israelische Militär ja in Pläne
nicht
reingucken und informiert uns dazu auch
nicht natürlich der Schabbat ist ein ein
Feiertag und äh auch im Militär sind
gläubige Juden für die der Schabbat
wichtig ist dennoch ist eine
Ausnahmesituation ein Notfall
auch eine Bedrohung des Landes ein eine
Ausnahmesituation wir z.B merken dass
wir gerade mit mit Kontakten und
Menschen die wir hier kennen heute auch
reden und telefonieren können obwohl
Schabbat ist und obwohl sie eigentlich
am Schabbat ihr Handy gar nicht nutzen
äh auch die machen heute eine Ausnahme
für wichtige Telefonate weil sie sagen
die diese Notsituation manche sprechen
ja von einer der existenziellsten
Bedrohungen Israels seit der
Staatsgründung diese Notsituation ist
einfach so so vehement und so groß dass
die schabatregeln da auch nicht beachtet
werden müssen lassen sie uns zum Ende
unseres Gesprächs einmal auf Gaza
schauen was hören sie zur Lage in Gaza
das Ultimatum dass das israelische
Militär gesetzt hatte B VI 2 Stunden den
Norden zu verlassen das ist ja jetzt
abgelaufen ja noch ist
da auch kein keine andere militärische
Aktivität zu beobachten es gab heute
Nacht einen Aufruf nochmals des Militärs
an ein Krankenhaus im Norden Gaza auch
das zu evakuieren das ist ein Ort der
relativ sicher ist an den sich wohl
viele Menschen zurückgezogen haben das
ist das was uns
unser Team das für uns arbeitet in Gasa
noch gemeldet hat gleich gleichzeitig
bleibt es bei Panik bei M Chaos die
Menschen wissen nicht wo sie hingehen
können also auch im Süden selbst wenn
sie dahinkommen äh ist völlig unklar wo
sie dain sollen da gibt's keine
Kapazitäten ähm das ist schon eine
humanitäre Katastrophe und auch unser
Team hat uns mitgeteilt dass nun geplant
ist Internet und Telekommunikation in
Gaza einzuschränken oder ganz
abzustellen das hieß auch für uns dass
wir dann keinen Kontakt mehr haben zu
unseren Informanten zu unseren Quellen
und dass wir dann
nicht wissen auch wie es Ihnen
persönlich geht und und wie sie heute
durch den Tag kommen Christian Limpert
ganz herzlichen Dank für die
Einschätzung von
Vorort so und sie sehen hinter mir
Livebilder aus Gaza aus Gaza Stadt vor
mittlerweile mehr als 12 Stunden ist das
abgelaufen das Ultimatum dass das
israelische Militär den Bewohnern des
Nordens von Gaza gesetzt hatte ihre
Häuser und Wohnungen zu verlassen und in
Richtung Süden zu fliehen ca eine
Million Menschen betrifft das in diesem
40 km langen Küstenstreifen der ganz eng
bebaut ist noch hat eine groß angelegte
Bodenoffensive nicht begonnen das haben
wir gerade noch mal bestätigt bekommen
laut Vereinten Nationen sind mehrere
10000 Menschen jetzt auf der Flucht nur
wohin Gaza verlassen das können die
Menschen nicht Israel hat alle Zugänge
blockiert und die einzige Grenze nach
Süden zu nach Ägypten die ist auch
geschlossen im Morgengrauen ist Gaza
noch immer das Ziel von Raketen oben die
Einschläge unten in suchen Menschen nach
etwas Schutz wir sind von der Außenwelt
abgeschnitten wir wissen nicht was da
oben gerade passiert wir wissen nicht
was mit uns passieren wird wie unser
Schicksal aussieht wir wissen noch nicht
einmal wohin wenn wir hier
rauskommen Stunden später dann fallen
Flugblätter vom Himmel abgeworfen von
Drohnen die israelische Armee ruft die
palästinensische Zivilbevölkerung auf
den Norden des Gazastreifens zu
verlassen mehr als eine Million Menschen
sollen sich auf die Flucht begeben in
Richtung Süden weg von Gaza
Stadt jemand muss uns retten wir begeben
uns auf einen kollektiven Selbstmord was
hier passiert ist nicht zu akzeptieren
was haben wir denn getan dass wir jetzt
obdachlos
werden sie haben Zettel abgeworfen sie
wollen das wir gehen warum wegen all der
Dinge die hier passieren
werden der Aufruf den dicht besiedelten
Norden des gaserstreifens zu verlassen
der bislang deutlichste Hinweis auf eine
bevorstehende bodenin der israelischen
Armee seit dem Überfall der Hamas feuert
Israel immer wieder auf Ziele im
Gazastreifen seit Samstag die Angriffe
sollen sich gegen die Infrastruktur der
Hamas richten die sich oft in mitten von
Wohngebieten befindet das Bild auf den
Straßen schon jetzt eine
Trümmerlandschaft von zerstörten
Wohnungen und Häusern mehr als 1800
Menschen sind nach palästinensischen
Angaben bisher gestorben Überlebenden
bleibt oft nicht mehr als das was sie
tragen können tausende haben sich auf
die Flucht begeben auf den Straßen Chaos
und lange Staus sie versuchen
rechtzeitig in den Süden des
Gazastreifens zu gelangen und
zugeschaltet aus Freiburg ist mir jetzt
Josef kutteru er ist Historiker
nasostexperte und Journalist einen
schönen guten
Morgen guten Morgen israel hat am Morgen
mitgeteilt das haben Sie sicherlich auch
gehört dass einer der mutmaßlich
Verantwortlichen des massakas jetzt
getötet word ist er soll der Leiter des
Hamas luftüberwachungssystems in Gaza
gewesen sein und eben
maßgeblich beteiligt jenseit natürlich
von dem Gedanken dass man einzelne Hamas
Mitglieder jetzt töten möchte zur
Verantwortung ziehen möchte hat sowas
Auswirkungen auf die
Hamas
Israel eigentlich betreibt diese
Strategie schon seit vielen Jahren also
israel hatte
schon im ersten Jahrzehnt dieses jtaus
angefangen
hamasführer systematisch wie Israel das
Netz zu liquidieren und
es wurden immer wieder
wichtige Kommandanten auch Mitglieder
der politischen Führung der Hamas
getötet aber es
rückten nachher immer neuere nach und
letztendlich bringt allein diese
Strategie nicht viel die muss ja als
teil einer viel größeren Strategie eben
auch diese militärischen die wir jetzt
sehen
Teil sein und ja ihre
ersten Einsätze waren nur
bedingtfolgreich sie kennen die Hamas
sehr gut von ihrer Struktur her
vielleicht können Sie uns einmal
erklären wie ist die Hamas aufgebaut und
wie wenn wenn Israel das Ziel verfolgt
die Hamas zu zerstören
wie kann das eigentlich möglich
sein die Hamas ist und das ist wichtig
zu wissen gerade in dieser
Zeit Zweig geteilt es gibt eine
politische Führung sie hat auch ein
eigenes sogenanntes Politbüro und es
gibt die den Pol den militärischen Arm
der Hamas das sind die kassan bririgaden
außerdem ist die Hamas eine sozial
ausgericht der Organisation sie hat also
eine starke Basis in der
palästinensischen Bevölkerung im
gazerastreifen und im Gasastreifen ist
die hamasbewegung auch entstanden also
das ist praktisch ihr Stammgebiet
ähm wie groß ist denn der Rückhalt in
der Bevölkerung in Gaza was die Hamas
angeht
der Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung scheint
sehr groß zu sein wir können das nicht
genau messen es gibt ja keine Umfragen
wie etwa in Israel
aber 60% der Bevölkerung sind ganz junge
Menschen es gibt immer wieder auch in in
den letzten Jahren Berichte darüber dass
viele junge Menschen wegen der
Perspektivlosigkeit wegen der ja
bedenklichen humanitären Lage im
Gasastreifen auch das Gebiet verlassen
wollen und auswandern wollen also es ist
immer schwer einzuschätzen wie stark der
Rück der Bevölkerung ist aber wie gesagt
es ist für die Hamas immer ein Heimspiel
dort ist sie entstanden sie ist aus der
Bevölkerung gaserastreifen aus einer
sehr traditionell ausgerichteten
Bevölkerung weit traditioneller als in
der besetzten
Westbank und deshalb ist ihr halt in der
Bevölkerung auf jeden Fall
garantiert lassen Sie uns noch mal sie
haben das eben schon mal angedeutet aber
noch mal auf die Ziele einer
militärischen Operation von Israel
eingehen das Ziel die Hamas komplett in
ihrer Kommandostruktur zu zerstören ist
das angesichts auch der der Situation in
Gaza wenn wir wissen Militärlager
Waffenlager sind unter oder in
Krankenhäusern ist das überhaupt möglich
die Hamas so zu zerstören dass Gaza
befreit von der Hamas
ist das ist sicherlich ristig möglich
theoretisch aber es ist natürlich auch
die Frage
wie groß der Pre wie hoch der Preis für
die Israel sein wird also was jetzt
geschehen ist durch diese sehr große
Opferzahl zum ersten Mal auf israelische
Seite ist das
so sozusagen ein ein
Dammbruch es ist zu einem dambmbruch
gekommen
es ist eine psychologische Barriere auch
bei den Israelis dadurch überwunden
worden so traurig es auch ist und äh ich
glaube dass die Israel ist die
israelische Regierung auch viel stärker
als früher auch bereit ist mit größeren
Bodentruppen in den Gaza Streifen
einzumarschieren und dabei auch sehr
hohe Verluste in Kauf zu nehmen und äh
das ist dann die Frage wie wie der Kampf
vor Ort dann stattfindet
ähm wie schon in dem Beitrag äh äh
angesprochen ist es natürlich sehr
schwierig in die Tunnel äh in die
untergirischen unterirdischen Tunnel
einzudringen und dort
Kampf zu führen stelle ich mir als sehr
sehr verlustreich Vung Herr kotteru
vielen Dank für den Moment wir sprechen
gleich noch mal weiter dann kommen wir
auch zu sprechen auf die Lage drumherum
auf die arabischen Länder in der Nähe
eben von Israel wir schauen jetzt aber
erstm auf Benjamin netanahu der hat
gestern Abend eine Ansprache an die
Nation gehalten und da noch mal auch
erklärt was das Ziel der möglichen
Bodenoffensive sein
wird Bürger
Israel Schabbat schalom für euch alle
Schabbat schalom für unsere
Streitkräfte unsere Streitkräfte die im
Lande sind über alle und sie haben den
Sabbat weit weg von zu Hause
gefeiert heute heute verstehen wir alle
und das es geht um das Haus wir kämpfen
um das Haus das Haus von uns allen wir
kämpfen wie
Löwen die soldatinen Soldaten die
Polizistin und Polizisten die
Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die
Streitkräfte und die Rettungskräfte und
ihr die Bürger
Israels mit diesem freiwilligen
Engagement wir sind alle rekrutiert wir
sind alle
vereint noch viel wird erzählt über
unsere Heldentaten in diesen Tagen in
diesen dunkelen Tagen wo wir Schmerz
haben von diesem schlechten bösen
Schabbat und das wird in die
Geschichte des jüdischen Volkes
geschrieben wir werden nie vergessen
über diese grultate was uns gemacht hat
ich habe mit einigen familienangehören
gesprochen Welt ist
zerstört ich
weiß wir werden nie vergessen die
grultatten unsere Feinde und wir werden
nie verzeihen und wir werden der Welt
auch nicht zulassen oder
jemanden diese grueltaten in
Vergessenheit zu bringen sowas ist noch
nie passiert in letzten 10 Jahren wir
kämpfen und wir schlagen unsere Feinde
beispielslos ich betone das ist nur der
Anfang unsere Freinde habe erst begonnen
nur den die Zeche zu bezahlen und ich
werde überhaupt nicht ins Detail gehen
was auf uns zukommt aber ich kann Ihnen
sagen das ist nur der
Anfang bei meinen Gespräche mit
Präsidenten beiden und mit
anderen Führer in der Welt und mit
großen Mühen rekrutieren Israel ein
internationale Unterstützung für unsere
Akten ich habe heute den amerikanischen
getroffen und die foretzung des Krieges
wir dadurch gesichert wir kriegen
weitere Munition und wir werden die
Hamas vernichten wir werden siegen es
wird noch dauern aber wir werden diesen
Krieg beenden Stärke als je
zuvor gott wird uns helfen gegen unsere
Feinde und sie werden
verlierenabatalom ja wir werden siegen
die Feinde werden verlieren das Benjamin
netanahu gestern Abend und zugeschaltet
ist mir weiter aus Freiburg Josef kuteru
Historiker
narostexperte Journalist Herr kueru
schauen wir einmal auf die arabischen
Nachbarländern es hat riesige
Demonstrationen gegeben z.B in Jordanien
da haben dann auch Menschen versucht die
Grenze zum Westjordanland zu Westbank zu
durchbrechen dann hat es natürlich auch
im Libanon große Demonstrationen gegeben
einer der Hisbollah Sprecher dort hat
gesagt wir stehen an der Seite der Hamas
für wie wahrscheinlich halten Sie einen
Flächenbrand momentan halte ich ein
Flächenbrand für eher unwahrscheinlich
m es ist
nicht im Interesse der hbullah insgesamt
jetzt einen also eine eigene Front mit
Israel zu eröffnen was wir bis jetzt
dort sehen also der
Nordfront sind eher kleine Attacken
sieideten meiner Ansicht nach einfach
der also der symbolischen
Funktion also dass die chrisba zeigt
dass sie irgendwas
unternimmt in den benachbarten
arabischen Ländern sieht es für die
Hamas nicht gut aus
Ägypten hat sehr angespannte Beziehungen
zur hamasführung die sie eigentlich als
ja feindliches Element betrachtet und
über die letzte Jahre versucht eine ja
eine Art Modus wie wen die ähnlich wie
die Israelis das getan haben zu finden
in Jordanien ist Hamas ein absolutes
Tabu
und
saudi-Arabien hat auch keine großen
Sympathien für für diese Islamisten
Organisation die Saudiarabien
verabschiedet sich in den letzten Jahren
allmählich vom islamischen
Fundamentalismus und trotzdem sie haben
es gerade angesprochen die Rolle
Ägyptens die Tunnel aus Gaza gehen ja
nach Ägypten kann Ägypten vielleicht
Qatar in irgendeiner Weise eine
Mittlerrolle einnehmen und in
irgendeiner Weise auch schlichtend auf
die Hamas
einwirken ja also Ägypten hat gestern
schon angekündigt dass
es an einer
kleinen regionalen Konferenz im Moment
arbeitet in der
qar also Qatar ist eine wichtige ein
wichtiges Unterstützung Land der habamas
vor allem in finanzieller Hinsicht
und dann auch noch
die USA und Saudi-Arabien auch
einbezogen werden sollen eventuell
sollte dann dieses Treffen an einem für
alle diese Beteiligten neutralen Ort
stattfinden es ist noch nicht klar wo
vielleicht sogar in Jordanien
ägypten ist ein ganz wichtiger Akteur
auf den auch die Israelis setzen und
Ägypten hat auch all die Konflikte der
letzten Jahre also ihre vorübergehenden
Beilegung
[Musik]
für für Israel
im Grunde erledigt also Ägypten ist als
Vermittler hier hat als Vermittler eine
ganz wichtige Rolle eine letzte Frage
Herr kuteru wie groß schätzen Sie die
Gefahr ein dass die israelische Armee in
im Gazastreifen in eine Falle tappt
nämlich auch deshalb weil zu erwarten
ist dass dort natürlich sehr viele
zivile Opfer ähm es dann geben wird dass
es Bilder geben wird die auch dann eben
herzzerreißend sind wenn man dann ähm
getötete Kinder im Gaza sieht dass dort
dann natürlich einerseits die äh
Unterstützer Israels ähm sagen werden oh
völkerrechtlich humanitär bitte haltet
euch ein geltendes Recht und
andererseits natürlich auch die Feinde
Israels noch mal mehr ähm gezwungen
werden in irgendeiner Weise mehr zu
unterstützen das kennen wir schon aus
aus
anderenitionen der Israel dies im
Gazastreifen das ist nichts Neues also
diese sie meinen eher so also diese
völkerrechtliche Problematik oder auch
die moralische aber ich möchte hier auf
etwas aufmerksam machen was bis jetzt in
der Berichterstattung kam kaum vorkam
nämlich was hat eigentlich die Hamas und
das ist auch der der islamische dihad
der mitgewirkt hat
ähm neben dieser großen Operation
äh sonst geplant also gibt es eine
weitere umfassende Planung für den Fall
dass die Israelis und das wollte die
Hamas auch provoziert werden und dann in
den Gazastreifen einmarschieren was dann
die Hamas unternimmt in militärischer
Hinsicht das wissen wir noch gar nicht
und bislang ist auch
mit diesem hat hat sich eigentlich mit
diesem Punkt noch niemand befasst das
wäre eine Falle Josef kreuteru ganz
herzlichen Dank für ihre Einschätzungen
für diesen Moment sie sind den ganzen
Tag noch für phöniix da und wir werden
später noch weiter zu Ihnen kommen ganz
herzlichen
Dank vielen Dank und nicht nur die
Vereinten Nationen auch
Menschenrechtsorganisationen sprechen
von einer dramatischen Verschärfung der
humanitären Krise in sie fordern ein
Korridor über den Medikamente
Lebensmittel Wasser geliefert werden
können was ist erlaubt im Krieg und was
ist vom Völkerrecht gedeckt das ist eine
Frage Antonio guterrisch forderte
einerseits das freilassen aller Geiseln
und verschleppten und er drang aber auch
andererseits darauf einen sofortigen
Zugang für humanitäre Hilfe zu
erleisten ich möchte hier ganz kurz auf
dietigen Botschaften eingehen die ich
dann dem Sicherheitsrat vorlegen werde
die Lage in Gaza hat ein gefährliches
neues Tief erreicht die abscheulichen
Terroranschläge von Hamas auf Israel
haben mehr als 1200 Menschen getötet und
tausende
verletzte am letzten Samstag darauf
folgte eine intensive Bombardierung von
Gaza dami sind schon 1800 Menschen ums
Leben gekommen und tausende weitere
verletzt nach verschiedenen Luftschlägen
hat Israel die Palästinenser in Gazas
Stadt und der Umgebung aufgefordert in
den Süden des Gaza Streifens sich zu
begeben aber mehr als eine Million
Menschen durch eine dicht besiedelte
Kriegszone an einen Ort zu bringen wo es
kein Nahrungsmittel gibt kein Wasser
keine Unterkünft wenn das gesamte Gebiet
belagert ist ist äußerst gefährlich in
einigen Fällen nicht möglich die
Krankenhäuser im Süden des
gaserreifens operieren schon am Rand ihr
Kapazitäten und sind nicht in der Lage
1us neue Patienten aufzunehmen das
Gesundheitssystem steht vor dem
Zusammenbruch die Stationen sind
übervoll mehr als 11 ang des
medizinischen Personals wurden in
Ausübung ihrer Tätigkeit getöt und es
gab 34 Angriffe auf
Gesundheitseinrichtung im ganzen Gebiet
herrcht eine Wasserkrise die
Infrastruktur ist zerstört es git kein
Strom für Pumpen und
sanlagen die Mitarbeiter der UNO und
unsere Partner arbeiten rund um die Uhr
um die Menschen im gazastraen zu
unterstützen wir betrauern den Tod einer
Reihen von Kollegen und wahrscheinlich
werden noch mehr ihr Leben riskieren ich
stehe in Kontakt mit politischen Führern
weltweit und in der Region um eine
weitere
Eskalation im westlderland und auch im
Südlibanon zu verhindern
der feuerwechsel über die blaue Linie
hinweg ist äußerst beunruhigend das muss
aufhören wir brauchen sofortigen
humanitären Zugang zum gazastrafen um
den Bedürftigen Treibstoff
Nahrungsmittel und Wasser zu liefern
auch Kriege haben ihre Regeln das
internationale humanitärrecht und
Menschenrecht muss geachtet werden
Zivilisten müssen geschützt werden und
dürfen nie als Schutzschilde benutzt
werden und alle Geisel in Gaza müssen
sofort freigelassen werden es ist
wichtig dass alle Parteien und
diejenigen die Einfluss a sie haben
alles tun um diese Ziele zu erreichen
und zum Schluss möchte ich noch kurz
eingehen auf den Hass der durch diesen
fürchterlichen Konflikt angestachelt
wurde im Nahen Osten und weltweit
entmenschlichende Sprache die zur Gewalt
auffördert kann man nie akzeptieren ich
fordere alle auf vorzugeen gegen
Antisemitismus und antimuslimischer
Heuchelei und Hassrede jetzt ist an der
Zeit dass die Gemeinschaft
zusammritte um Zivilisten zu schützen
und eine dauerhafte Lösung für diesen
nicht endenden Zyklus von Tod und
Zerstörung zu
finden Liebe Zuschauerin und Zuschauer
soweit von uns die
sonderberichterstattung zur Lage in
Israel und dem Nahen Osten um 13 Uhr
meldet sich meine Kollegin Ines Arland
mit einem Update hier geht es jetzt im
Programm weiter mit einer Dokumentation
die ich Ihnen ans Herz legen möchte 75
Jahre
Israel
[Musik]